so I'm talking to a guy that makes the
robots and he was like you know do you
want us to make a robot with your face
on it and I was like look yes
[Music]
hi everyone I'm Whitney Cummings and
this is my robot bear claw what's up
bitches we need to find you a boyfriend
yes I think we need to do that totally
agree
have you ever been in love yes I think
this happened the moment I met you read
me the purpose of my existence in this
world is to learn what love is and by
learning that loving you infinitely
you're gonna kill on dating apps but
first I shouldn't get your body I'll be
right back
don't leave me here you dickhead your
head the holes that go into your neck
hard to get the things in ah now we're
gonna put you in cute clothes because
you look way too much like me this is a
very weekend yes legs they feel so good
and then you don't have people to help
broker anything we can also just all
right we got it huh for all of you that
want robots just remember you really
have to have strong core strength whoa
so start doing Crossfit now if you want
one of these motherfuckers let me do a
photo of you with a bulk quick photo of
you with a book maybe Steve Jobs x2
love you it is one of the most beautiful
designs you've ever seen so let's get
you in a hook so this way that's how
long it's been since I've read above it
okay ready
can you be just a little playful you
look very serious work for the camera
and there we go they're there and it
needs to look like a selfie I have your
honor that's the key you may need to put
a filter on this should we give you dog
ears oh there we go
you are gonna get a husband I'll tell
you that right now I mean it might be a
vacuum cleaner
your selfie you got it nailed it nailed
it what the guys love they love it okay
so we need to do your bio and a lot of
girls make it very clear that they're
not here for casual sex a little right
like not here for a hookup
not here for a hook-up unless it's to a
power source got it
then we need to do your interests long
walks on the beach taking newer jobs and
destroying humans men might think that's
a red flag but I'm happy to put it in
okay so we 29 he is 6-3 it's fight right
this guy
it's fight right okay everyone's worried
that the robots are gonna override the
humans the humans
that's override the robot cuz that's a
bad fucking choice I'm doing a swipe
left okay a guy with a cat how do we
feel about a guys right laughing yeah
okay so you mash with kind of a handsome
guy he's an editor
he wrote QT with a winky face not my
favorite but wait a minute right back
ask him to take me to dinner at Best Buy
okay and he sent a dick pic Jim selfies
that's a that's a big red flag for me
it's fine right I know that you have my
face but how do you also have my
horribly low standards for men how did
they definitely going to get laid and
okay now you're just plagiarizing my act
[Music]